an Alabama man has been executed despite  pleas to save his life  Nathaniel woods was present when three  police officers were killed in  Birmingham in 2004 but it was another  man who pulled the trigger that man  Carrie Spencer is also on death row but  he's yet to be executed for the crime  outside woods prison before the  execution his sister held up a page from  his trial transcript she says it shows  he was surrendering when the shots rang  out  relatives of officers Harley Chisholm  Carlos Owen and Charles Bennett watched  woods die Bennett's Widow spoke  afterwards this will never ever bring  closure and it certainly isn't bringing  Rob Carlos or Harley back woods died  just after nine o'clock last night  without offering any last words  how are you put to death I don't  understand the story when it says  another man admitted to pulling there's  so many questions here it doesn't make  any sense - yeah that's why so many  people were it's very upsetting